[Musique]
herman le gall bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue ici le petiot à montigny le
bretonneux pour votre café politique au
cours du prochain quart d'heure nous
allons parler de votre parcours vous
êtes maire-adjoint de maurepas
conseiller communautaire délégué de
saint quentin en yvelines et membres
toujours du parti libéral c'est votre
formation politique voilà pour
l'étiquette politique au civil vous êtes
entrepreneur manager dans le secteur
hospitalier
oui vous exercez toujours cette activité
alors j'ai toujours aux activités au
sein de l'entreprise
même si je vous cache pas que c'est un
petit peu compliqué d'être consultant
sur un territoire où vous êtes élu donc
vous allez voir ailleurs ça n'est pas
simple mais oui j'ai tire toujours nos
activités actuellement c'est obligatoire
pour vous justement de garder cette
activité professionnelle aux civils et
d'avoir un engagement politique pour pas
être complètement coupés aussi il faut
garder ce pied dans le civil il faut en
plus et j'adore ça voilà et puis vous
savez la politique c'est ingrat docte ça
s'arrête
j'espère que ça va continuer ça peut
s'arrêter non mais c'est important
en tout cas pour mon équilibre la sphère
familiale oublie souvent mais il faut
c'est d'équations à avec 3,3 intérêts la
politique pour moi ma vie
professionnelle
et puis la vie personnelle il ya une
complémentarité entre votre activité
professionnelle et votre engagement
politique
ou est-ce que vous et séparer les deux
ou est ce que l'un sert à l'autre aussi
vous vous nourrissez de la main d'autres
alors c'est une excellente question et
complémentarité je dirais pas ça une
culture par rapport à la politique oui
j'ai plusieurs bada
j'en parle pas souvent la première des
choses c'est que je suis très attaché la
restauration collective et au bien
manger c'est un enjeu de santé publique
que l'on minor vraiment au delà du bien
manger et de tout ce qu'on entend que le
gaspillage le sucre etc etc
il y a aussi un élément est un facteur
important au niveau des cancers et au
niveau du coût de la sécurité sociale
voilà je vais pas vous faire un débat
maintenant parce que ça prendrait trop
de temps mais en tout cas il ya un enjeu
important et je crois que les pouvoirs
publics doivent prendre en prendre
conscience
rapidement très rapidement et pas en
mettant des lois et par des taxes en
arrière je crois qu'il ya vraiment une
pédagogie auprès des enfants à avoir ça
commence doucement l'obésité on arrive
simplement rayé mais c'est quelque chose
qui est vraiment
fort et un engagement qu'il faut prendre
vraiment à bras le corps le deuxième
chose c'est le vieillissement de la
population
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui manie
encore plus parce que on sait que la
démographie en france le s'accélère
la population vieillit et à côté de ça
on à la silver économique est en pleine
croissance
et qu'est ce que l'on fait à la croisée
des chemins avec tout ça il y à un
certain nombre de start-up qui regarde
ça de près le bien manger également les
maisons de retraite
certes un enjeu considérable en france
mais on est vraiment très très loin
puisque font les canadiens ou des états
unis sur certains secteurs
donc ça c'est vraiment des enjeux
importants et moi ça m'a mis énormément
bon voilà on fait partir on entend vos
engagements politiques aussi arrière
tout ce que vous nous dites vous avez
commencé très jeune en politique est
tout de suite au parti libéral alors
quel est le parcours un peu politique
d'avoir politique en fait il est
moi je suis attaché à des valeurs
je suis à à dreux on dort et voir alors
dreux est très connue parce que c'était
une des premières villes du front
national et lorsque la famille stirbois
est arrivé à dreux j'avais 14 ans et je
peux vous dire que quand vous avez 14
ans et vous voyez des grands bouts de
crs dans votre ville dès qu'un événement
politique
eh bien vous vous interrogez soit vous
passez à côté cet événement puis
littoral
c'est la vie moi je suis pas passer à
côté je me suis ça m'a interpellé
donc tout de suite j'ai regardé un peu
plus près ce qu'est ce que ça voulait
dire la gauche et la droite
et surtout qu'est ce qui était le front
national voilà et le front national je
sais ce que c'est je l' ai vu et vécu de
très près avec tous les enjeux et toute
la perversité que peut avoir ce parti à
partir de ce jour là je me suis engagé
voilà et donc vous avez décidé de
rejoindre la voix des libéraux
alors en fait évidemment vous êtes à 14
ans vous inscrivez vous observez j'ai eu
ma vie professionnelle d'étudiants aussi
donc je me suis pas engagé entièrement à
cette période-là mais j'observe
énormément la politique moi je me suis
engagé surtout il ya un homme politique
sur lequel j'avais beaucoup n'ai pas eu
encore beaucoup d'estimé ce qui n'est
pas décédée c'est un peu retiré de la
vie politique c'est jean louis borloo
voila voila c'est un homme lorsqu'il est
arrivé à valenciennes qui a fait des
choses mais ça c'est génial c'est ça la
politique
c'est d'arriver avec des convictions et
de dire je vais arriver à changer faire
venir une entreprise grosses entreprises
là d'étiquette politique
ouais et après les libéraux si vous
voulez je me suis retrouvée il ya quatre
ans a en fait il ya eu le déclic par
rapport à ce que aurélien véron lorsque
je les rencontre et tout ce qu'il a
dégagé 2
du parti libéral vvd mais c'est moi
voilà fondé ce parti en 2008
oui parti libéral courant que les
avocats qui avaient fondé une
association liberté chérie voilà est en
fait dans ses valeurs je me suis
vraiment retrouvé voilà parce que il ya
malheureusement les libéraux sont tout
de suite
attaché au libéralisme économique mais
c'est pas que ça et moi j'ai des valeurs
autres que l'économie oui parce que dans
l'opinion publique alors forcément en
politique ceux qui s'y intéressent vous
un petit peu plus loin que ça mais dans
l'opinion publique on peut penser parti
libéral libéralisme économique
libéralisme débridé liberté absolue pour
les uns et les autres et puis mettre de
côté un peu le social est ce que c'est
ça le parti libéral et non je provoque
un peu non mais non c'est pas ça juste
non mais vous avez raison c'est je vous
ai dit vous avez posé la question sur
mon parcours professionnel et regarder
tous les deux fois je lui ai parlé c'est
du social ces lits plus ni moins que du
social
non c'est simplement parce à la sécurité
par exemple
moi je suis pour c'est que le premier
engagement des libéraux c'est aussi de
vie dans un pays en liberté et la paix
et en liberté s'impliquer en sécurité
voilà ça c'est un vrai engagement les un
engagement aussi c'est à voir
libre de droit de cotiser où on veut à
la sécurité sociale autres voilà ça
aussi c'est un engagement fort et on
peut avoir une analyse fine économique
pour ne pas laisser à côté tout le plan
social mais faut pas faire n'importe
quoi et surtout c'est la phrase clé et
phare du parti libéral c'est l'état
nounou lors qu'un moment dès qu'il ya
quelque chose on doit tout de suite met
une loi et ça c'est juste enfin c'est
insupportable alors et pour moi c'est
que je trouve que plus on avance à
pierce et même aujourd'hui avec ce
changement de gouvernement il ya eu un
changement de ligne politique aussi les
limites un peu poussé classé il ya une
recomposition politique encore en cours
que ce soit à gauche ou à droite
est ce que les choses avancent dans le
bon sens par rapport à l'action qui est
menée aujourd'hui président c'est la
question que vous pose en tout cas vécu
témoin je trouve pas mais je trouve
qu'on fait du picking à gauche à droite
ne voit pas jusqu'au bout d'un flat tax
d'ailleurs dans l'hémicycle était peu
nombreux
euh ya peu de députés c'est une idée qui
émane des libéraux et qui était son
programme de fillon voilà donc on fait
du pitti on va pas jusqu'au bout
revoir la loi travail ok mais moi je
suis j'y reste sur ma faim
encore une fois la suppression de l' isf
enfin écoutez ça fait 30 ans qu'on en
parle vous croyez que taxer les 20 plus
riches sur leurs gros voiliers ça va
changer la vision des millions de
chômeurs je crois pas franchement là on
est on est à côté on passe à côté de
plein de choses mais on est dans des
écrans de fumée sans arrêt moi je suis
quand même inquiet en tant qu'élu local
par exemple sur la suppression des taxes
d'habitation
là par contre ça m'inquiète principales
sources de revenus pour les
collectivités locales exactement la dgf
le fonds de péréquation enfin on est en
train de mettre de niveler vers le bas
ça c'est une certitude
côté son gouvernement jai ho moi j'ai
sûrement assuré sur une chose c'est
peut-être le ministre de l'éducation
nationale peut-être voilà puisqu'on a eu
quand même gauche ou droite que des gens
vraiment qu'ils ne sont pas allés
jusqu'au bout des choses en tout cas
qu'ils ont voulu mettre les projets de
loi pour avoir un nom encore une fois
avant de passer par l'intérêt général en
passe pour son propre intérêt
bon là on a quelqu'un qui semble
regarder c'est un peu plus de prix plus
près parce que c'est important
tant mieux aujourd'hui l'opposition est
plutôt cristallisé est représentée par
jean luc mélenchon c'est plutôt lui
qu'on présente comme force principale
d'opposition il ya un travail important
à faire ne serait ce qu'à droite
oui oui au centre à gauche on n'en parle
pas mais pour l'instant les repartir
alors il ya deux choses c'est de
repartir sur des vraies idées et non pas
sur des marronniers et puis regardez un
peu ce qui pousse derrière
la jeunesse et des jeunes élus des
quadras quand être un peu plus
d'expérience mais il ya une nouvelle
force qui arrivent là il faut regarder
ça avec beaucoup d'intérêt et ne plus
arrêter cette politique ou en place sans
arrêt les mêmes qui ne voient plus de
toute façon dans leur sphère politique
soit depuis des années donc là il ya un
vrai enjeu et vous avez raison
en plus ce côté très révolutionnaire de
mélenchon
fait qu'on l'entend et ça fait bien le
jeu de macron en plus voilà du coup il
n'y a pas que la droite
même la gauche la gauche et atténue on
entend plus si on revient à des
questions ou des préoccupations plus
local pour terminer cette séquence
cette émission maurepas à la commune de
maurepas vous aussi siégé donc en tant
que les élus de la majorité maurepas
depuis depuis quand depuis quand
avez-vous rejoint cette commune de
maurepas lisant voilà avant j'étais à
versailles mais alors l'anecdote et qui
n'en est pas une c'est pourquoi je la
connais depuis tout petit puisque j'ai
de la famille qui était au bas de
maurepas donc j'ai connu lorsque les
gens médias mais vous n'avez pas connus
quand ils avaient le crêpa si j'ai connu
toute cette période avec les commerçants
la halle couverte et c'est notre mort
pas je connais depuis très longtemps et
je suis revenu parce que je connaissais
mais cette commune de maurepas
aujourd'hui vous la voyez a évolué et
comment il ya eu du changement aussi à
une alternance en portant sur sept
communes de maurepas et qui a été
dirigée par la même équipe pendant des
années et des années
le travail qui a été fait par vos
équipes l'avenir que vous envisagez pour
marc pas moi je vois un avenir confiant
j'ai confiance au maire et
et au-delà
[Musique]
de nos liens amicaux et aussi des
obédiences politiques
c'est quelqu'un qui est très visionnaire
sur la ville qui a déjà à long terme
et qui me rassure parce que il y met un
vrai équilibre de territoire donc moi on
implore d'ailleurs que samuel maurepas
donc je suis très confiant avec ça je
souhaite que cette ville progresser
évolue aussi avec une population un peu
plus dense qui s'équilibre et il ya
certes un enjeu fort à revoir
effectivement pour terminer un petit
questionnaire c'est le principe dans
cette émission c à la règle l'actualité
au sens large est ce que vous êtes
plutôt valérie pécresse ou laurent
wauquiez pécresse plutôt plate club
house of cards ou baron noir comme sauf
qu'à sa ferrari
et puis pour terminer plus tôt ryder cup
aux jeux olympiques brighter rider ce
sera pour 2018 les gigots faudra
attendre 2024 pour 50 ans mercy est ron
légal hershey maire adjoint de maurepas
élus de l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines vous étiez invité pour ce
café politique émission que l'on
retrouvera très prochainement sur notre
antenne merci à vous verser
[Musique]
et